you're welcome black people i'm here
fighting on your behalf
i think this summer taught us that
racism is real much more real than we
care to admit
if you're black you probably already
knew my bad we finding out late
and i feel bad because my black friends
used to tell me all the time a black man
has to be twice as good as any white man
to get half the credit
and i didn't accept it and that's my bad
i used to be like no my parents are
immigrants
i was an idiot black man does have to be
twice as good as any white man to get
half the credit
and you know what made me realize that
harvey weinstein
this disgusting blob of a human being
looks like the poop emoji
he gets to be the spokesperson for the
most important movement in modern
history
that's [ __ ] vile and if you think
about harvey weinstein's victims what
are we talking
25 30.
meanwhile
bill cosby
upwards of 60 women and nary word about
this man
harvey weinstein gets to be the face of
the most important movement in history
bill cosby's still doing [ __ ] pudding
there's always room for jell-o ass bill
cosby that's what he's stuck with
black man can't get no credit in this
world
that's [ __ ] up this is an injustice
and we got to correct you
you're welcome black people i'm here
fighting on your behalf
[Applause]
can't let these [ __ ] crackers have
everything
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty